this FIFA executive used an onion
article as proof to defend himself
against corruption charges to the
uninitiated the onion is a satirical
newspaper this is Jack Warner he was the
vice president of FIFA and in 2015 he
was one of several FIFA officials
charged with fraud racketeering and
money laundering I know this because I
made a giant video about FIFA corruption
I know way too much about this
organization but I had to cut this
tidbit because it just didn't fit but
this one's just too good not to share
Warner recorded a video of himself
holding up this obviously fake article
which says that FIFA had announced an
impromptu 2015 World Cup that was
starting that very day he thought it was
a genuine news report and he held it up
as evidence that there was an American
conspiracy to get back at FIFA for not
choosing them to host the World Cup I
mean just to skim through this article
reveals how clearly satirical it is it
ends by saying the U.S was leading the
defending champs Germany in The Opening
match getting 12 penalties in the first
three minutes but even still